mais d'abord notre journal de campagne
avec flora sauvage direction pleut havre
a
accueilli au havre la ville de son
ancien premier ministre edouard philippe
par des chants entonnés par une dizaine
de gilet jaune emmanuel macron tente de
convaincre les électeurs de gauche car
au havre jean luc mélenchon est arrivé
en tête au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
à dix jours du second tour le président
candidat est interpellé sur la colère
des étudiants
le jeu la colère pur solution donc il
faut réussir à montrer qu'il ya une
ambition derrière et donner un rôle à
chacun pour convaincre abstentionnistes
électeurs de gauche emmanuel macron a
choisi pour ce déplacement la thématique
de l'écologie avec la promotion des
éoliennes en mer alors que marine le pen
veut un moratoire sur leur implantation
le projet de madame le pen et de
complètement stoppé les énergies
renouvelables et de le remplacer par des
centrales nucléaires skinn as je le dis
ici avec beaucoup de clarté pour nos
auditeurs aucun sens en termes de
temporalité parce qu'une centrale
nucléaire qu'on décide aujourd'hui au
mieux elle entre en fonctions en 2035
donc elle ne couvre rien des besoins
dans les 15 ans qui viennent et sortir
du renouvelable aujourd'hui est une
aberration complète nous serions le seul
pays au monde à le faire emmanuel macron
aimerait rattraper le retard de la
france en matière d'énergies
renouvelables s'il est réélu mais le
duel avec marine le pen s'annonce
beaucoup plus serré qu'en 2017
les électeurs écologistes ce sera l'un
des thèmes de notre débat tout de suite
avec laure salvaing bonsoir bien vous
êtes directeur général de kantar public
france jérôme sainte-marie bonsoir
sondeurs politologues a pris dans
l'institut pôle inbox jean garrigues
bonsoir pression du comité d'histoire
parlementaire votre livre la tentation
du sauveur c'est aux éditions payot et
lætitia krupa éditorialiste politique
bonsoir
laetitia quand emmanuel edwards se
retrouve on pourrait titrer ça comme une
histoire d'amitié quel bilan vous tiré
de cette journée havraise alors celle là
alors
déjà je pense que c'est un acte fort un
acte symbolique important de la part d'
emmanuel macron d'aller à la fois dans
la ville de son ancien premier ministre
qui aujourd'hui encore est la
personnalité politique préférée des
français c'est lui qui a la cote
d'avenir auprès des français la plus
élevée 1 42% des français dans notre
dernier baromètre figaro magazine pour
epoca nous disait effectivement qu'il
souhaitait qu edouard philippe compte
dans les mois à venir et dans les années
à venir en france et puis aussi
symbolique parce que comme vous le
rappelez dans le
dans le reportage jean luc mélenchon
était premier est un des premiers au
premier tour dans cette ville c'était
important aussi pour tout l'est l'un peu
de centre-droit et de droite de montrer
que emmanuel macron est proche d'edouard
philippe c'est assez étonnant d'ailleurs
quand on regarde la gestuelle entre les
deux ces deux hommes politiques est
assez franches qui est assez
sûre d'elle et c'est
certain débat viril josé pas oui parce
que j'ai envers link n'a pas forcément
été simple entre les deux hommes depuis
que j'ai dormi pas quitter la halle à
matignon à voir si on regarde l'histoire
des couples exécutifs sous la vème
république sont en train de faire en ce
moment pour notre travail ça c'est pas
passé si mal que ça ça s'est plutôt bien
passé mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
tensions et des tensions qui sont déjà
deux au moment de la crise et gilet
jaune et des tensions qui sont aggravées
à partir du moment où edouard philippe a
commencé à avoir une cote de popularité
qui dépassait celle du président de la
république ce qui est d'ailleurs assez
classique emmanuel macron considérait
aussi que edouard philippe n'avait pas
joué suffisamment son rôle de bouclier
de bouc émissaire de fusible comme on
dit
c'était ensuite à concurrence qui est qu
est née très très clairement puisque on
voit bien que étant donné l'état de
déliquescence des républicains il ya un
avenir mais ce que vous venez de dire il
ya un avenir pour pour edouard philippe
alors qu'a priori si jamais si l'
aventure manuel macron été réélu
président frais son quinquennat et son
aventure politique a priori serait
serait terminée tandis que celle
d'edouard philippe ne fait que commencer
donc il ya il ya un enjeu la majeure de
recomposition parce que c'est ça au fond
je pense moi que l'une des
significations de cette visite c'est
aussi pour résoudre un peu les tensions
qui se sont produites au moment où
emmanuel macron à a construit cette
grande maison commune de du centre droit
et de la droite et à bloquer la fusion
alouettes a réagi exactement donc il ya
là des frictions qui sont réelles
c'était important d'aimer paul dano noah
conte de montrer qu edouard philippe le
soutenait en dépit de ces frictions mais
les problèmes ne sont pas résolus pour
l'avenir jérôme sainte-marie si on va
beaucoup parler de report des voix
encore dans cette émission est
logiquement dans l'est dans les dix
jours qui viennent si on regarde les
électeurs de valérie pécresse il ya 30 %
des électeurs de valérie pécresse qui
disent aujourd'hui qu'ils sont prêts à
voter marine le pen est ce que une vie
comme celle là ça peut parler à ses
électeurs de valérie pécresse oui
certainement mais c'est à dire que comme
l'a souligné laure salvaing edouard
philippe à une image extraordinairement
positive extraordinairement déjà parce
qu'il ya plus élevés puis
extraordinairement par rapport au fait
que s'il a une image de modération dans
l'exercice du pouvoir notamment lors des
crises et j'ai des jaunes il était
extrêmement dur en fait beaucoup plus
que présent de la république beaucoup
plus déterminée mais bon ça fait partie
des paradoxes de formation de l'opinion
et il peut parler effectivement aux
catégories relativement âgées qui
composent désormais l'électorat de
droite qui composaient déjà une majorité
de l'électorat de françois fillon donc à
la fois modération fermeté et puis
surtout l'idée que décidément emmanuel
macron et est capable de rassembler tout
de même de lever tout le monde et de
faire taire effectivement c est celle
histoire de rivalité donc c'est le jeu
que chez actuellement emmanuel macron
comme d'ailleurs marine le pen qui
doivent s'adresser à des publics l'un et
l'autre à des publics différents et en
grande partie opposée près donc voilà
c'est la complexité en pagne
d'entre-deux-tours évidemment construire
le matin on s'adresse à jean l'étoile
jean luc mélenchon et l'après midi si on
est pour lens électorale donnaient mme
pécresse et d'autres et puis pour
l'autre lectorat de d'eric zemmour enfin
c'est quand même assez c'est quand même
assez fort et donc là effectivement je
pense que ça s'adonne à la fois un
message à la droite mais tout en restant
dans un registre de modération était
responsable gouvernemental
l'ex premier ministre est là il a
finalement été assez discret dans la
campagne de premier tour peut-être que
il a été plus discret que ce qui était
prévu parce qu'on peut dire ça oui en
fait il a illustré la modération vous
avez trouvé le mot juste vous avez
raison alors ça va vraiment à contrario
de tout ce que les équipes ont dit avant
que ça commence vous savez avant que
emmanuel macron ne se déclare on voyait
l'entourage du président et tous nous
disait vous allez voir il aura vraiment
un rôle pivot et b une expression qui
revenait souvent dans nos discussions
s'étaient il va mouiller la chemise
edwards bon après il ya eu les faits la
réalité
ça a été plutôt modérée sans mouillage
de chemise il a soutenu à minima c'est
vrai qu'il a soutenu un il a fait un
meeting par exemple à nice sans emmanuel
macron et puis les observateurs avertis
se sont rendu compte qu'il était quand
même bien préoccupé par le sort de son
parti politique horizons pour les
législatives et on voit cette modération
au message qu'il a publiées sur les
réseaux sociaux le lendemain du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
regarder et puis on en discute après 6
comment on est attaché à une france qui
est grande lorsqu'elle tient à cette
idée de liberté alors je crois qu'on
doit s'engager pour le président de la
république faire campagne activement et
prendre ses responsabilités et voté le
24 avril pour emmanuel macron prochain
ne sais pas si c'est moi mais on ne sent
pas un enthousiasme débordant dans cette
vidéo d'ordinaire la communication
électorale est plus offensive plus
clivante donc là il fait un peu le
service minimum edouard philippe est bon
alors c'est peut-être son style à vous
avez raison la modération l'euphémisme
mais c'est surtout que derrière tout ça
il y à son destin et vous l'avez dit
jean garrigues son destin à lui edouard
philippe peut-être futur candidat en
2027 alors il est un peu coincé dans le
en même temps finalement de son ex
patron c'est à dire que il dois le
remercier il n'était rien avant qu
emmanuel macron ne le nomme à matignon
personne ne le connaissait donc il doit
le remercier de la part mis en lumière
mais il doit lui seul rester dans cette
lumière pour construire sa stature de
futurs potentiels chef d'état si si je
suis un peu provocateur est ce que laure
salvaing edouard philippe a vraiment
intérêt à ce qu emmanuel macron sera élu
parce qu'ils ont fait un peu de
politique fiction emmanuel macron
l'emportent si edouard philippe se
présente dans 5 ans ça fait presque un
troisième mandat macro n'ya d'une
certaine façon ou maquereau nist je
pense qu'il arrivera quand même à se
à se démarquer à un moment ou un autre à
se démarquer je pense aussi qu'il ya un
enjeu important et on les oublie aussi
ce sont les abstentionnistes
ce premier tour qui ont voté ou qui
avaient voté françois fillon en 2017 et
je pense que ceux ci sont très proches
aussi des idées notamment de d'edouard
philippe et que c'est aussi pour capter
cet électorat là parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de l'électorat mélenchon
premier tour il est déterminant pour
pour ce second tour mais en fait il ya
quand même là les absences ils furent
séduits c'est plus de 12 millions 10
millions une personne qui sont pas allés
voter c'est le premier parti de france
c'est 5 millions de plus que les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
évidemment il ya un réservoir poteau et
à l'intérieur de ces abstentionnistes je
me dis qu'il ya une grande part qui
était fille aunis en 2017 il ya d'une
part pas une grande part mais une part
qui était effectivement électeurs
finissent ya une part qui était
également électeurs de macron qui se
sont abstenus au premier tour et une
part aussi des lecteurs de marine le pen
et puis une petite part mélenchon mais
surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ce ne sont pas forcément des
abstentionnistes habituel voyez les les
abstentionnistes du premier tour la de
2022 tous ne sont pas abstenus il y a
cinq ans donc ce sont des gens ont peu
mobilisé c'est intéressant je sais pas
comment vous le voulez value et saint
jérôme sainte-marie parce que il ya cinq
ans on avait une abstention plus
importante au second tour qu'au premier
oui je me souviens bien ça je sais pas
si ça va se se rééditer cette fois ci
mais en tout cas c'est un risque
et donc et donc la capacité de parler
aux absentionnistes sauf qu'ils sont
dans tous les camps politiques
c'est ça les abstentionnistes cette fois
ci donc on revient au grand écart dont
on parlait tout à l'heure autrefois si
vous voulez à la présidentielle
généralement ont voté davantage au
second tour qu'au premier le record de
participation c'est le second tour de
1974 je passe sous votre contrôle il me
semble qu'on était à 86 87 %
participation ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est à dire que dans les
abstentionnistes il ya quand même une
part irréductible de gens qui n'iront
pas vous dire dans la période la plus
dramatique on avait le choix entre les
socialo communiste et le les démocraties
libérales au choix quoi on avait c'était
effectivement il ya quand même 13% ou
14% des gens qui sont restés chez eux
donc on voit bien que c'est pas faux pas
trop tous les abstentionnistes bien
entendu ça à peu près 10 points
probablement qui sont mobilisables
savent que désormais ce puisqu'il ya une
dispersion de paysage politique qui
n'est plus du tout organiser surtout au
niveau national par le clivage gauche
droite il ya effectivement des forces
qui ne sont pas représentés au second
tour et c'est bien c'est pour ça que
lors des dernières élections
effectivement il ya eu une abstention
relativement importante des gens qui
avaient voté à droite par exemple pour
françois fillon ou à gauche pour jean
luc mélenchon qui ne se sentaient pas
concernés par ce second tour et là on
aura très certainement quand même une
abstention forte du côté en tout cas de
jean luc mélenchon alors on va parler
d'écologie tout de suite avec alexandre
poussard parce que le thème de ce
déplacement des balmes à condom soir
alexandre s'était notamment l'écologie
vous allez regarder ce que le le
président candidat a fait en matière
d'écologie est-ce qu'il a tenu les
promesses de son début de quinquennat
alors thomas globalement non mais il ya
tout un contexte qu'on va évidemment
rappelé alors certaines promesses n'ont
pas été tenues par exemple emmanuel
macron promettait d'augmenter les taxes
sur le diesel pour lutter contre la
pollution aux particules fines il l'a
fait la première année mais très vite il
ya eu la crise des gilet jaune et donc
les taxes sur les carburants ont été
gelé emmanuel macron avait aussi fixé
l'objectif de servir à 50 % de produits
durables dans les cantines dans les
restaurants d'entreprise une loi a bien
été votée mais elle a du mal à
s'appliquer aujourd'hui et donc on est à
seulement en moyenne à 15 % de produits
durables dans les cantines et puis
concernant l'agriculture emmanuel macron
avait promis à la fin du glyphosate dès
2020 ça n'a pas été réalisée même
d'ailleurs le président de la république
n'hésite pas à parler d'échec sur ce
sujet sur la trans et sur la transition
énergétique beaucoup d' objectifs n'ont
pas été atteints emmanuel macron voulait
et bien concernant les énergies
renouvelables justement il voulait
doubler la capacité de la france en
énergie éolienne et solaire des progrès
ont été fermés aujourd'hui on est et
bien au milieu de la trajectoire prévue
sur le nucléaire en 2017 et bien le
candidat macron voulait à baisser la
part du nucléaire à 50% de notre mix
énergétique très vite nicolas hulot a
retardé et bien donc objectifs prévus en
2025 très vite nicolas hulot l'a retardé
à 2035 et ça c'était avant à la fin du
quinquennat ou emmanuel macron a annoncé
la relance de la construction de
réacteurs nucléaires et puis toutes les
centrales à charbon devait fermer dans
notre pays à la fin de son quinquennat
ce ne sera pas le cas notamment dans un
contexte de tensions sur la production
d'électricité donc ça c'était pour la
colonne - du bilan écologique est ce
qu'on trouve dans la colonne plus il ya
quand même une colonne plus avec
certains objectifs attend comme celui de
verser 100 mille prime à la conversion
par an pour changer les vieux véhicules
polluants
l'objectif a été atteint et même
quasiment doublé et puis il ya également
l'interdiction d'explorer du gaz de
schiste et des hydrocarbures sur notre
territoire ça c'était et bien une
demande de l'accord de paris sur le
climat ça a été instaurée sous le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro et puis
emmanuel macron avait également promis
de rénover 50% des passoires thermiques
pour les propriétaires les plus modestes
et là notamment grâce à la loi
énergie-climat 2019 et bien à des
actions ont été menées aussi le
dispositif ma prime rénove qui a connu
un certain succès avec 650 mille
logements rénovés mais on peut mettre
quand même un petit point
d'interrogation à caron n'a pas l'outil
statistique pour dire si cette promesse
a été tenue et puis on finit par quand
même deux lois qui on est bien beaucoup
de mesures écologiques comme la loi
climat en 2021 qui reprenait à certaines
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat et puis la loi anti gaspi
et pour l'économie circulaire qui a
imposé de nouvelles normes de nouvelles
pratiques aux entreprises merci
alexandre pour tous ces détails on
regardera le programme de marine le pen
en la matière tout à l'heure et est ce
que tient justement jean garrigues ça
peut être l'un des domaines l'écologie
ou emmanuel macron a peut-être plus de
grain à moudre une marge de manoeuvre
qu'une marine le pen pour aller chercher
des électeurs soit ce dynamique jadot
soit ce écologistes à ses nombreux qu'on
votait jean luc mélenchon j'ai
l'impression étant donnée la la
fragilité du programme écologique de
marine le pen et les idées notamment le
refus du renouvelable ou bien qu'elle
est aujourd'hui a annoncé enfin
réorienter un peu ça sa politique donc
c'est un angle sur lequel effectivement
a priori les plus solides avec toujours
ce handicap c'est que lui il est d'abord
dans un bilan sur lequel on peut le
critiquer l'attaqué en disant qu'on n'a
pas fait suffisamment et puis aussi sur
des propositions qui de manière
objective sont plus larges et plus
conforme à aux idées des écologistes ou
des électeurs écologistes que celle de
marine le pen mais je répète qu'ils sont
adjointes à ce bilan qui lui va être
jugé insuffisant donc s'il s'agit
d'aller chercher les électeurs
écologistes qui représente d'ailleurs un
gisement finalement assez assez étroit
parce que le sort de ce corps de yannick
jadot a pas été important mais qui
peuvent être complétées par des
électeurs mélenchoniens puisque je pense
qu'une des motivations du vote mélenchon
ça a été aussi l'écologiste hop aux
lecteurs jeunes et bien voilà il est il
ya un gisement qui n'est pas énorme et
puis il ya capacités aussi de le
critiquer sur ce sur ce point donc voilà
c'est je pense que c'est un des points
quand même dans le cas de duels du 20
avril c'est à un point sur lequel il
peut être un peu plus fort que d'autres
mais c'est pas ces tables de son bilan
ce qui est intéressant c'est la
perception de son bilan laure salvaing
parce que alexandre poussard palais
parler de deux lois importantes de ces
dernières années la loi climat et
résilience et puis la loi à gec pour
l'économie circulaire ça provoque quand
même des mutations
de beaucoup de secteurs industriels à
des filières qui sont en train de se
créer c'est assez intéressant pour
respecter la loi mais ça alors là c'est
passé totalement sous les radars des
électeurs qu est-ce qu on retrouve la
convention citoyenne pour le climat les
promesses n'ont pas forcément été tenue
donc son bilan il est perçu globalement
une façon négative absolument en gros il
ya à peu près un tiers des français qui
considèrent que c'est un bon bilan en
matière d'écologie et d'environnement
etc et donc deux tiers qui considère que
ce n'est pas le cas et puis je pense que
pour les français c'est un sujet très
difficile enfin pour les français pour
les citoyens d'une manière générale vous
voyez on avait fait une étude pour le
magazine l'hémicycle qui nous qui nous
montrait que quasiment un français sur
deux nous et qu'ils avaient pas les
moyens financiers aujourd'hui de
favoriser la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et cédera que
eux mêmes n'avaient pas les moyens c'est
quelque chose qui leur semble vraiment
très compliqué et dans quand leur
demande quand on leur demande
spontanément qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire ils disent en 1 en fait sont des
changements de comportement est
aujourd'hui moi je suis trop fragilisé
pour changer les comportements à l'heure
actuelle et notamment parce que
finalement et vous parlez des électeurs
mélenchon les électeurs mêlant chant
effectivement c'est leur troisième
priorité mais leurs deux premières c'est
le pouvoir d'achat et les inégalités
sociales donc le sujet de
l'environnement non seulement c'est un
petit effectivement un peu une petite
réserve
délectera et puis en plus c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est demander des
efforts aux français quand aujourd'hui
en gros ils sortent
c'est la faute des politiques parce que
on a effectivement l'impression qu'on
est toujours culpabiliser dans cette
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
de façon individuelle alors que il me
semble que des solutions holistique
serait beaucoup plus efficace et puis
nous déculpabilise ray d'une certaine
manière et pourrait inclure les classes
populaires parce que c'est les classes
populaires dont on parle et qui se
sentent complètement décorrélé de cette
problématique et c'est aussi le problème
des manuels macron qu'il y ait de deux
tiers des français qui jugent son bilan
négatif pourquoi parce que l'enjeu
écologique oui mais le bilan des manuels
macro négatif les deux tiers des
français pourquoi parce qu'il me semble
qu'ils ne le connaissent pas bam et non
à partir oui à partir du moment et qu'il
est quand même et il vient de faire un
quinquennat il essaie lui le mieux placé
pour pouvoir expliquer aux français les
points positifs en matière d'écologie de
son bilan il l'a fait une fois son bilan
lors de sa conférence de presse fleuve
de quatre heures où on était
complètement noyée je pense que les
français n'ont rien retenu donc si vous
voulez qu'on retienne des mesures phares
qui ont compté et qui sont un peu
symbolique pour vous faire confiance à
pour un nouveau mandat le faire c'est
vrai qu'il ya une forme de un peu
d'amnésie poste qu'ovide post crise coin
c'est à dire que finalement il ya plein
de choses peut-être qu'ils ont été
réalisés mais avec ce qui s'est passé
oui tout cela réduirait oui mais ça aux
gens ce que vous disiez c'est la
problématique pouvoir d'achat finalement
elle et elle l anesthésie où elle écrase
un peu celle de l'écologie oui alors la
préoccupation sur l'écologie c'est une
préoccupation presque universel dans la
population française est d'ailleurs les
français font des efforts regardez
comment tout le monde s'est converti au
tri sélectif mais quelque chose et
négligent se l'appliquent non pas parce
qu'ils se sentent surveillés qui
pourrait voir des amendes et sonnerat
mais très naturellement ils le font très
pour les entreprises aussi agir j'y
reviens je le fais tu reçu un peu têtu
sur l'économie circulaire c'est des
secteurs entiers qui sont obligés de
changer parce qu on appelle ça la
responsabilité élargie du producteur
donc ils peuvent plus brûler ou mettre
en décharge des invendus ils vont être
obligés de les intégrer à une visière
d'économie circulaire c'est vraiment une
révolution j'assiste aussi le caractère
hautement interclassiste comme c'était
fort et y compris sur l'alimentation il
ya quand même des marchés bio qui se dé
qui s'est développée autrefois cette
émission télé quand les fans ça donnait
aussi dur
qui permettent une certaine économie
locale il se joua sur un gong est
produit par des baux logique de troc etc
vous avez vraiment ça se développe
réellement c'est pas uniquement s'est
pas uniquement les bobos et c'est ça
existe alors après pour emmanuel macron
pour répondre à votre question ça paraît
assez difficile de communiquer sur son
bilan pour l'écologie à la mesure où ces
clament des questions techniques assez
complexe des questions fiscales
également assez complexe et où les
résultats a pris russes ne sont pas là
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas l'être c'est
à dire que le dérèglement climatique ne
doit pas être stoppée par cinq ans
d'action du présent arrêt plus français
qu'elle puisse face juste sur le long
terme sans vote une loi avec un bilan de
nous et 30 c en 2030 composent sa vaste
show il ya aussi une gêne
gouvernementale pour communiquer trop là
dessus parce que tout de même la grande
crise la seule fois finalement le
pouvoir d' emmanuel macron a reculé ça a
été ça n'a jamais été une mobilisation
des syndicats et la ddh ailleurs une
mobilisation de l'opposition
parlementaire d'ailleurs ça ne le sera
pas non plus dans le quinquennat
prochain si jamais les réglages et c'est
par contre ça a été le fps de climat
semi insurrectionnel qu'on a connu en
novembre décembre 2018
l'occasion tout de même une prime sur le
carburant qui était justifiée à tort ou
à raison par la préoccupation écologique
et à partir du 10 décembre et du retrait
de cette prime à finalité écologique en
tout cas dans le gouvernemental le
mouvement s'étiole et changent de nature
et c'est très important parce que ça
veut dire que dans le la mentalité
collective dans la perception des
français ils se disent l'écologie c'est
quelque chose de répressif c'est quelque
chose que je fais c'est aussi pour ça
que yannick jadot a pas d'impact mais
dans sa confiance parce que je pense que
là était personnes un jeune monsieur
souffrance ça plus le le vote utile à
gauche plus bien sûr le manque de
peut-être de charisme du candidat plus
les divisions au sein de l'écologie mais
cette notion là à mon sens elle est
essentielle pour expliquer pourquoi
cette thématique que tout le monde
partage au fond elle n'arrive pas à un
prénom on a fait un focus sur le bilan
on va dire des manuels macron mais si on
regarde le programme de marine le pen
il n'y a pas d'objectif précis sur la
baisse des émissions de co2 sur le
nucléaire il ya l'objectif d'une
construction de nouvelles centrales dont
3 p r à un moratoire sur le
démantèlement de fessenheim
sur les éoliennes alors là il ya un
point intéressant suppression des
subventions allouées à l'éolien et au
solaire arrêt des chantiers en cours et
sur les passoires thermiques des
subventions pour remplacer les
chaudières au fioul produit est impoli
pas de logements verts et manu macron il
a attaqué sur les éoliennes aujourd'hui
jean garrigues s'est pas c'est pas non
c'est pas quand ils cherchent à parler
aux électeurs de jean luc mélenchon et
de yannick jadot et ça c'est très clair
il faut dire que la france est très en
retard sur le parc éolien ou marité
mighty bon jeu pas besoin de de faire un
par rapport aux britanniques aux
norvégiens on est formés on est très en
retard c'est un sujet fait diamant parce
que le coeur de cible quand même je
pense monde et de l'électeur écologistes
enfin le club son idéologie ce sont les
énergies renouvelables c'est pas la
cepal nucléaire donc lui en soutenant
sept 7 ans maintenant ce cap vers les
énergies renouvelables qu'il qu'il
jouxte avec le nucléaire il est quand
même dans la ligne 2 des électeurs
écologistes c'est quelque chose qui leur
parle mais mais le problème étant que
est-ce que ça ça parle aux électeurs par
exemple de jean luc mélenchon en tout
cas aux électeurs des couches populaires
de jean luc mélenchon ne sut pas sûr
qu'il se disait il nous faut absolument
un petit peu quand même quand emmanuel
macron par le choix qu'il a employé le
terme de planification écologique c est
très mais très mélenchonisme
mélenchoniens sa tournée il n'y a pas
plus composites que l'électorat et jean
luc mélenchon de dimanche dernier oui
pas de votre foi mais de dimanche
dernier c'est très très composite
notamment parce qu'il s'est construit
dans les dernières semaines à travers le
vote utile donc je ne crois pas
sincèrement qu emmanuel macron se fasse
le moindre illusion sur sa capacité à
récupérer la partie du vote populaire
qui va sur mélenchon c'est à peu près ce
pas négligeable c'est 23% je crois que
les ouvriers les employés les rachats
par les justes je donne je donne les
chiffres ipsos oprah steria sur les
reports de voix des électeurs
mélenchonistes pour l'instant tout ça
est ce que c'est possible d'évoluer 33%
vers manuel macron 18% vers marine le
pen et l'immense majorité de 49 % celles
et ceux qui s'abstiennent dans
l'électorat écologiste dans l'électorat
notamment qui veut du reste de la gauche
ou des écologistes qui a rallié emmanuel
macron il ya une partie que
son pardon mélenchon une partie qu'il
maniait le maquereau peut récupérer
cette partie je plains désigné par un
terme qui peut vous surprendre mais qui
renvoie à la fois une position sociale a
une mentalité c'est ce qu'on appelle la
petite bourgeoisie et vous avez tous ces
petits bourgeois qui sont qui trouvent
que l'écologie c'est pas mal parce que
des gens ils ont peut-être une
préoccupation mais ça leur permet de ne
pas se situer sur les enjeux économiques
et sociaux où ils sont un peu entre deux
chaises si j'ose dire et c'est l'été les
gens qui n'aiment pas du tout ma chromé
qui n'aimait pas du tout léger des
jaunes non plus de vous raconter une
anecdote juste une seconde alesi seconde
j'étais sous près de l'arc de triomphe
ont observé les gilet jaune en lors de
vous savez de la 110 du fouquet's même
des affrontements très dur avec des gens
cassé provoquant même biais du blog blog
mais beaucoup de prolos qui était sur le
lait français lisez et à ce moment là
c'était le jour du climat c'était sept
voiliers cette manifestation
donc on agit alors que les affrontements
étaient vraiment très important sur la
belle qu'à police on a vu un immense
cortège arrivait depuis le trocadéro qui
allait vers république est là les jeunes
gens avec des tee-shirts verts
d'alternatiba se sont disposés avec une
corde pour bien séparer leur cortège des
gilet jaune et orienter le cortège de
climat vers ensuite une autre avenue
pour parer à ce mélange cette image que
j'ai pu immortaliser si vous voulez
était extrêmement forte parce que outre
ces deux manifestations c'est normal que
ça donc ça prouve qu'il ya pas de
convergence des luttes déjà et surtout
ça prouve deux milieux deux milieux qui
ne se rencontrent pas et qui ne peuvent
pas se rencontrer inversement ils
peuvent être attendre ils peuvent être
relativement sensible à ce que dit
emmanuel macron et inversement rebutés
par le choix pro nucléaire je crois
majoritaire maintenant dans l'opinion au
pro nucléaires des deux marines de bani
alors on va continuer de discuter de et
d'analyser ce le report possible de cet
électorat composite mélenchonistes mais
d'abord je vous propose d'aller
finalement l'entendre lui donner la
parole c'est marion delpech qui s'est
rendue à lille lille le candidat a
soumis fait 40% au premier tour c'est un
record regarder à lille jean luc
mélenchon est arrivé très largement en
tête du premier tour réunissant plus de
40% des voix et plus encore dans le
quartier cosmopolite de wazemmes pour
ses électeurs une question se pose
désormais que feront ils le 24 avril
prochain pour voter c'est sûr après
votre c'est quoi c'est encore la grosse
question h et voter au second tour et
suis très très inquiète de ce qui va se
passer il faut vraiment que les jeunes
restent mobilisés je vous mets en poche
de voter blanc parce que voilà j'y crois
plus 3 la politique est comme il disait
coluche si le vote est changé quelque
chose bas ça ferait longtemps que ça
serait interdite s'ils ne sont pas
encore tous décidé pour le second tour
les lillois sont en revanche unanimes
l'opération séduction menée par le
président sortant sur la gauche n'aura
pas d'influencé sur leur vote je sais
très bien que ça c'est clairement pour
ne récupérer mais bon dans un sens si je
prends mon exemple
moi j'ai pas besoin de ça pour
directement je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec ce type là mais c'est comme j'ai
dit par défaut juste pour pas que
l'autre passe donc moi c'est pas quelque
chose qui va influencer ses plus de mon
point de vue personnel côté écologie qui
va être important je ne le fais pas du
tout confiance il nous a déjà fait le
coup il y a cinq ans il a refait le coup
plusieurs fois ce qui concerne
l'écologie et puis ensuite c'est la
dégringolade il fait exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il a dit il y a
également les déçus dont certains
affirment que la candidature du
communiste fabien roussel aurait privé
jean-luc mélenchon d'accéder au second
tour certains sont allés jusqu'à
vandalisé les locaux de la fédération du
pcf du nord un acte que condamne le
responsable administratif si on n'est
pas forcément d'accord avec le parti
communiste il ya des façons de faire
qu'ils ne doivent pas exister
aujourd'hui dans l'or dans la vie quoi
je n'ai rebondir les discussions sans
véritablement en arriver aux mains
derrière la grande déception des
militants la fierté d'avoir réussi à
mobiliser pour atteindre un score inédit
de près de 22% le chef de file des
insoumis s'en remet à une consultation
de sa base de soutien avant de donner
une consigne plus clair ce que nous
proposons de faire c'est que toutes les
personnes qui ont soutenu jean luc
mélenchon dans cette élection
présidentielle puisse se prononcer sur
ce qu'elles vont faire au second tour
une consultation a du coup été mise en
ligne sur la plateforme action populaire
point fr ou les personnes toujours
soutenu jean luc mélenchon peuvent dire
ce qu'elle pense faire au second tour
jean luc mélenchon qui a lui même appelé
à ce qu'aucune voix aille à l'extrême
droite a précisé que quel qu'en soit le
résultat il ne devrait pas être
interprété comme une consigne laure
salvaing c'est cette phrase l'a martelé
par jean luc mélenchon pas une voix à
madame le pen c'était dimanche soir dans
son discours post résultats du premier
tour est-ce qu'elle a quand même un peu
imprimé dans dans l'esprit l'état
d'esprit de son électorat alors
justement gens ne souhaitent pas réviser
son électorat de 2022 est vraiment très
particulier
je pense que quand il part à sa base
effectivement il est tout à fait entendu
et des militants la france est soumise
effectivement attendre ce genre de
message il ya une partie quand même de
son électorat du premier tour là qui
sont selon lui didier environ 20% qui
potentiellement pourrait voter pour
marine le pen donc c'est pas forcément
un vote d'adhésion pour la majorité où
la banque très grande majorité de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon c'est
aussi pour faire barrage pour changer le
système et c'est donc aucune voix pour
marine le pen il est obligé de le dire
je pense pour son socle et sa famille
politique en revanche à une partie on
voit bien ya quand même 20 % de son
électricité tentés par le vote marine
ont parlé des arguments ou des éléments
de programme chez mm macro qui pouvait
séduire une partie des électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon il ya aussi des arguments
dans le programme de marine le pen on va
faire un débat tout à l'heure sur les
institutions le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne ça parle à une partie de
l'électorat mélenchon oui ou non cette
jérôme sainte-marie et ensuite on joue
quand même un mot faut que les choses
par rapport à la déclaration du 10 avril
de jean-luc mélenchon elle renvoie
strictement à une stratégie
parlementaire c'est-à-dire une stratégie
d'appareils que je fasse comprendre en
2017 je passe vous souvenez cambadélis
avait dit à l'époque a été à la tête du
ps nous avons vécu des moments très
difficiles le soir du premier tour et on
s'était dit si jamais mélenchon appelé à
battre marine le pen clairement et à
voter pour macro ont de fait et bien
dans ce cas là il aurait pu recomposer
la gauche à sa main et pour combler se
réjouissent et qui n'est pas qu'il
espère rester dans une certaine bulle on
comprenait plus tôt en 2010 est qu'il
appelé à s'abstenir même si les mots
n'étaient pas très différent mais le
message passe et qu'il fallait plutôt
s'abstenir pour les habitants de
mélenchon et là il a justement il
souhaite récupérer les plans qu'il a
passée il est passé du populisme à
l'union de la gauche il souhaite avec
faire le plus important possible c'est
de la stratégie et les temps d'appel
deux fêtes a voté pour macron sur
environ survient il soutient macro et
s'abstenir ou voter il serait bon c'est
tout le monde comprend qu'il est qu'il
est qu'il est qu'il annonce comme vous
avez deux candidats donc c'est pour
favoriser la construction d'une majorité
enfin une majorité d'un là d'un nouveau
jeu va prendre a sonné d'une quinzaine
de d'élus à
à 40 ou 50 pourquoi pas négocier avec la
gauche en position de force se répartir
les circonscriptions ray est comme ça
alors vivre l'homme a répondu à ma
question sur l'origine adobe je vais
imposer à jean garrigues le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
est-ce que ça ça veut parler une partie
de l'électorat mélenchon ce n'est pas ce
que ça fait c'est ta position l'analyste
bl alors et fernand oui oui alors on a
vu d'ailleurs que emmanuel macron
c'était avait dit qui finalement ce
n'était pas une mauvaise idée et non
plus que ça on y vient cette cette
question du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne ou 10 référendum tout court
parce qu'elle parle surtout d'une
pratique référendaire fessard et quand
marine le pen en s'appuyant d'ailleurs
sur aussi sur les demandes des gilet
jaune mais enfin c est une pratique
référendaire alors
c'est quelque chose qui semble
aujourd'hui s'imposer dans la dans la
vie politique française où le la
consultation l'idée de consulter plus
souvent le peuple est quelque chose qui
semble partager de plus en plus c'est
une demande sociale on va dire cette
idée du référendum maintenant l'histoire
je suis n'oublie pas les dérives que
cela a pu engendrer dans le passé et le
la dérive plébiscitaire notamment le le
fait qu'une majorité d'idées sur une
question par oui ou par non
simplifie forcément les enjeux etc donc
il ya beaucoup de questions qui se
posent autour de ça et puis moi ma
conviction que c'est que le colon dire
que la réforme institutionnelle doit
aller bien au delà de simplement le la
pratique est enfin là la réhabilitation
de la pratique référence il ya bien
d'autres choses à faire me semble t la
première des choses est temps de
découpler les deux élections ça c'est un
autre débat et puis surtout ce sera le
débat quand on propose
au téléspectateur dans une quinzaine de
deux minutes je voudrais qu'on ouvre un
chapitre autour de l'image de marine le
pen et c'est ça ça n'a pas évidemment
sur cette stratégie deux d'entre eux
dont deux tours et peut-être aussi sur
un peu le traitement médiatique autour
de la candidate du rassemblement
national l'image de marine le pen qui
n'en finit pas d'étonner le sénateur
claude malhuret on écoute moi je suis
très très étonné de voir comment elle a
réussi à gommer en quelques mois l'image
et la réalité le scanner ça fait trois
mois qu'elle se présente en bernadette
soubirous qui a découvert la démocratie
mais le personnage il n'a pas changé le
programme il n'a pas changé il était il
est exactement le même et laure salvaing
on rentre dans une c'est vraiment une
campagne différente la campagne de
second tour et est alors on avait évoqué
la campagne miaou c'était raté j'ai dû
me out mardi ensemble bon et la façon
dont marine le pen a réussi à faire
évoluer son image peut-être que les
journalistes ont pas assez creusé son
programme et là on y est quoi et elle y
est elle aussi d'une certaine façon avec
les conférences de presse programmatique
qu'elle a fait cette semaine donc ça
elle est clair et ça pousse les
journalistes et ça poussera emmanuel
macron a
pointé peut-être des contradictions ou
en tout cas aller sur le fond du
programme et ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment une autre campagne qui démarre
absolument et d'ailleurs on le voit
elle est beaucoup plus comment dire
attaquer frontalement par emmanuel
macron que lors de la campagne de
premier tour ou alors vous parlez de
campagne house est vrai que c'était a
été peu chahuté finalement et là
vraiment ça y est on vend on voit un
affrontement beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
sévère l'image de marine le pen elle est
assez intéressante dans l'opinion parce
qu'après 2010 est vraiment c'était
catastrophique 1 les les français a le
sentiment qu'elle s'était complètement
planté après ce débat de second tour et
qu'elle aurait du mal à remonter et en
fait petit à petit nous clôturons l'état
de l'opinion sur l'image du
rassemblement national et de marine le
pen est en fait on voit qu'elle a
amélioré petit à petit vraiment son
image jusqu'à avoir finalement le des
niveaux assez comparable à 2017 avant le
avant le débat et puis dans l'opinion
des français aussi elle a gagné sur des
thématiques et sur des traits d'image
qui leur sont très très cher la
proximité c'est elle qui gagne le match
de la proximité avec
emmanuel macron est considéré comme
beaucoup plus proche des préoccupations
des français emmanuel macron y compris
auprès des électeurs mêlant chant
premier tour est intéressant
la proximité l'honnêteté et la capacité
à réformer le pays c'est quand même des
dimensions qui sont assez importantes et
je pense qu'on a encore un an ou deux on
n'aurait pas parié sur ses dimensions
dans l'opinion un coup d'oeil au
baromètre ipsos sopra steria pour le
parisien et france info sur les
intentions de vote pour le second tour
on a un emmanuel macron à 55% et une
marine le pen à 45% écart de dix points
qui est quand même important alors je
sais - selon d'autres instituts
jérôme sainte marie un dernier mot tient
sur le débat alors j'aurais pu poser la
question à l'historien aussi le débat
est beaucoup disent y va être décisive
il ya des électeurs écolos qui disent
j'attends de voir le débat pour me
décider entre blancs et et votre mac
rond par exemple ou lors cette question
du débat elle se pose de manière assez
originale puisque l'ancien ayant été le
précédent ayant été perdus très
nettement par marine le pen et encore
plus dans la mémoire collective
probablement qu'en réalité les fautes
déjà c'était pas terrible mais plus
maintenant c'est devenu quasiment une
mythologie vous voyez ce que je veux
dire donc donc elle va faire que mieux
quoi ce qui pour moi exactement
raisonnement était simpliste voulait
qu'on fait tout de suite effectivement
c'est pour cela après marine le pen va
se heurte actuellement à au mur du
commentaire au mur du commentaires
médiatiques pour une raison très simple
vous connaissez ma thèse de bloquer
lutter contre bloc populaire il suffit
d'aller voir un kiosque que j'ai acheté
mon journal tout à l'heure et le kiosque
on aurait dit un mur de d'asie bao anti
le pen c'était parce qu'évidemment la
presse écrite est acheté uniquement par
des cadres mais là j'étais quasiment
uniquement par des gens qui ne votent
pas du tout pour marine le pen et quelle
que soit l'opinion des journalistes leur
public en tout cas aboutit à ce que
toutes les unes mais telle espèce de
cris d' alerte l'urgence le drame je pas
qu elle alerte développer la serbie non
ça sert un tout petit peu par réaction
auprès d'un électorat politisé
en réalité la diabolisation ça
fonctionne et je pense que c'est un vrai
problème c'est à dire qu'effectivement
vous avez dans le commentaire médiatique
vous ça sera émis par des gens qui à 95%
et bien enfin celle à diaboliser ces
deux fronts sens
implique aussi parce qu' est-ce qu'on
diabolise ou est ce qu'on dit vraiment
quel est le programme de marine le pen
derrière ses personnages de femmes
devenues soudainement docile voilà donc
dire les choses est factuellement
analysé mesure après mesure peut-être
que la titraille est anti le pen non
mais je ne suis pas là pour défendre mes
confrères et consoeurs mais je suis
juste très objective et dans tous les
journaux pour le moment on va vraiment
dans le fonds du programme pour une fois
enfin jean gary un goût du débat il ya
eu des débats décisifs par pas beaucoup
de mémoire plus le plus l'écart et
resserré avant le débat entre les
candidats et c'était le cas en 1974 et
en 1981 par exemple et avec des
victoires très courte d'abord de giscard
et ensuite de mythe et en plus le débat
prend un relief une importance et on
sait bien qu'a priori on avait considéré
que giscard avait gagné le débat 202 14
c'est qu'il est élu président mais pas
le monopole du coeur et puis françois
mitterrand revient aux 80 et la ludi est
traitée d'homme du passé mais dommage qu
entre temps vous soyez devenu le
président du passif donc voilà c'est ça
peut être un tout petit déterminant ce
n'est jamais un tournant c'est toujours
quelque chose qui amplifie me
semble-t-il une dynamique une différence
mais quelquefois comme en 2007 ça peut
être une catastrophe et on vous
proposera mercredi une soirée spéciale
sur public sénat et lcp la chaîne
parlementaire l'émission sens public ce
sera
à 18h et évidemment et puis ensuite le
débat en direct et un débrief juste
après autour de 23h merci à tous d'avoir
participé à notre débat jean garrigues
la tentation du sauveur et donc publié
aux éditions pailloux